un test pcr préventif tous les trois
jours c'est la réalité des résidents de
shanghai ils se remettent à peine de
confinement strict de deux mois qui
s'est terminée à la mi mai into his ce
résident d'un crois qu'un seul test par
semaine serait suffisant la chine
maintient sa politique coved 0 mais
changement important la quarantaine pour
les cas de contacts rapprochés ainsi que
pour les voyageurs arrivant de
l'étranger est réduite de moitié
losing my own commandé par bush auquel
elle sera désormais de sept jours dans
un centre gouvernemental suivi de trois
jours à la maison
les tests fréquents et autres
restrictions semble être là pour rester
cependant la politique que vide 0
chinoise risque d'être appliquée pour
les cinq prochaines années
jusqu'à ce printemps taïwan ou s'ils
étaient ancrés dans une politique de
kobe 2-0 confinement des résidents
mesure de distanciation sociale ces
mesures ont été assouplies au moment où
les confinements chaotique en chine
défrayé les manchettes
taiwan accepté de subir une nouvelle
vague de cas afin de marquer son
approche différente de celle de la chine
davantage le contrôle de la pandémie que
les droits de ses citoyens
le ministre de la santé de taiwan pas
nous ajoute
cet expert lui croit que taiwan n'avait
pas le choix d'adapter sa stratégie à ce
qui se fait ailleurs dans le monde
le chauffeur de taxi cheng chi s'estime
chanceux de ne pas subir les
restrictions sanitaires chinoises il
constate cependant que ses clients lui
parle encore de la pandémie lipumba de
nous et qu'ils ont aussi peur qu'avant
une nouvelle vague de kabal l île depuis
l'assouplissement des mesures en avril
dans ce marché public de taipei les
allées demeure moins achalandées qu'à
l'habitude
cet employé a perdu la moitié de son
chiffre d'affaires elle espère revoir sa
clientèle le retour à une vie plus
normale demeure timide à taiwan et les
touristes ne peuvent pas y contribuer
les frontières demeurent fermées pour
l'instant et c'est philippe leblanc
radio-canada tp